Mm,
in the United States right now is many
people have noticed that we are,
uh,
we are seeing a huge escalation of our
long running culture war.
Unfortunately,
universities are right in the heart of
that.
So the,
the right and especially right wing
media love to show video clips of
students saying outrageous things they
love to say.
The university is our bastions of
political correctness.
They've lost their minds.
The left is motivated to say no,
there's no not a problem.
There's nothing going on.
It's just that the right hates ideas.
They hate universities.
What Greg and I do in the book is we
say,
no,
we're,
we're going to cut through the culture
war.
Let's just look at what's going on.
Let's look at what a university should
do.
Um,
and so when we talk about identity
politics,
which is a controversial topic,
we start by saying,
of course you need identity politics.
Identity politics is not a bad thing.
Automatically.
Politics can be based on any
distinction.
It can be based on any group interest.
So for gay students or black students or
women to organize,
that's identity politics,
that's perfectly legitimate.
The question is how are they organizing?
What's the overarching framework,
and we've seen two versions of it in
American history.
You can do it the way most of the civil
rights leaders did it.
Martin Luther King in particular,
where you draw a larger circle around
the group,
you emphasize what we have in common and
then you say some of our brothers and
sisters are being denied equal access,
equal opportunity or equal dignity.
That works.
That has worked historically in much
tougher times and zones and that works
and we'll work on college campuses.
The other way you do it,
which is growing on college campuses,
is common enemy identity politics.
It's based on the bed when notion me
against my brother,
me and my brother against our cousin,
me and my brother and cousin against the
stranger.
It's a very general principle of social
psychology.
If you try to unite people,
let's all unite against them.
They're the bad people.
They are the cause of the problems.
Let's all stick together.
That's a really dangerous thing to do in
a multiethnic society,
especially in a university where we're
actually all trying to work together to
solve the problem we have to work on our
speech climate,
uh,
in the business world is called speak up
culture.
In the academic world.
It's called just basic openness to
ideas.
When you put people together and you
want them to talk,
of course people have a lot of different
goals and fears.
Nobody wants to say something stupid.
Nobody wants to say something.
We'll get them into trouble.
If you can create a really trusting
environment in which we're all in this
together,
contribute your ideas.
If someone says something that you think
it's wrong,
say,
so that's going to lead to more
innovation.
That's gonna lead to more progress.
But what if,
what if you have an environment in which
if I say something that offends anyone,
they can report me anonymously to hr or
some other,
some other entity.
I'm going to think three times before I
speak up.
That's what we have on campus.
I'm in the bathrooms at my university.
There are signs telling students had
report me anonymously.
If I say anything that offends them,
so I don't feel free to speak up when
I'm on campus,
I can speak more openly off campus,
but on campus,
I have to watch myself.
As one student said to a friend of mine,
my motto is silence is safer,
just shut up and you won't get in
trouble.
Now,
this is a terrible speech climate.
A university cannot function if people
are defensive in this way.
So in universities,
uh,
in,
in organizations that value innovation,
we have to not just encourage people to
speak.
We have to assure them that they're not
going to be shamed,
humiliated,
or punished for sharing an opinion and
good faith.
Look,
we have a culture war raging all around
us.
It's very easy to take offense.
People are understandably angry here
within these walls.
We have to put that aside.
We have to trust each other.
We have to give each of the benefit of
the doubt,
and it's going to be good for all of us
to do that.